all right come on here huh thank you
guys
I really like that one credit lives in a
band some people were on broad city I
sleep in a band pretty much the same
thing right the reason why I sleep in a
band because if you live in a bank you
don't have to do anything you don't want
to do except live in a band
the reason why I live in a man is
because I want to dedicate my life to
comedy full-time if you don't think I'm
funny tonight I'm sorry I'm trying
really hard I'm at peak performance
right now I really have no excuses at
this point I know someone's in the back
like yeah that was funny but not living
your band for me
gonna run that joke in an apartment it's
pretty hard to date when you're in a van
because ladies love shelter
so even if the day goes well what
usually happens is we go for a drive
until I can work up the courage to tie
we arrive 45 minutes ago surprise
surprise I love a love comedy you know
sometimes I wish I was a painter because
I've never been painting a picture into
the canvas be like babe draw something
Asian my I am Asian doesn't know this
country Chinese I'm from a Province in
China called South Korea right next to
the Japan province you know a lot of
people make fun of Asian people because
we dogs which I understand can be very
shocking because in America dogs are
treated like family members but in
America and Asia which in her family
members like family members this is very
little tradition we have instead of
buying an animal we love our grandma
[Laughter]
unless she's a baby girl in which case
we throw in the river you know I am a
you should American and I happen to
enjoy eating General Tso's chicken okay
my friends make my Asian friends like
dude isn't that just a shitty
Americanized version of something
authentically Asian I'm like yeah this
so am i my favorite movies rush hour 3 I
am single I have yet to meet my soul
mate I'm beginning to think maybe it's
her fault she needs to get out more
she seems like a loser I think I can do
better
[Laughter]
my friends like dude how'd you learn how
to talk to women maybe or maybe women
should learn how to listen to Hans why
don't you want to hear about the Federal
Reserve
is very interesting this this is one
lady I was talking to was like did you
know that my vagina is technically a 3d
printer because it can produce a baby
like incorrect actually your womb is a
3d printer your vagina is the tray a
very good 3d printer only prints one
thing with lots of errors takes nine
months to print and the whole time it's
printing is complaining
needless to say it and not any trades at
night I'm on brother women give birth I
feel like if man gave birth we'd be like
bro I've been eating so much protein and
creatine during my pregnancy this baby's
like 27 pounds right he's ready those
gains in the first trimester homophobia
people will be like it's Adam and Eve
not Adam and Steve but I don't need were
not even good couple biblically first of
all they just a bit got a native fruit
they weren't supposed to eat which is
kind of gay
there is Cain and Abel and Cain murdered
Abel why are they taking parenting
advice from people raised a murderer
there are only three other people on
earth
[Music]
to kill a quarter of the world's
population an [ __ ] you're a start-up
get your [ __ ] together pass the genetic
diversity on I am NOT a Christian I'm an
atheist because I'm not in kindergarten
and have an internet connection I think
it'd be stressful to have an ideology
that can be destroyed by facts walking
down the street oh look [ __ ]
fossil I guess I could have been blowing
dudes its all-time high I work at a
sushi restaurant right now most of my
job is to stand there and look Asian
I've been doing since day one I'm pretty
good at it by now
I uh I love working on sushi rice is not
to make Asian noises every now and then
I am sacrificing my personality for the
good of the group
I paid minimum wage and they expect me
to dedicate my life to handing people
food so you paid for the basic package
you get my motor functions and
peripheral vision
you want my creativity you're gonna have
to spring friendly 17 bucks an hour
you just have to show me you care I'm a
lady for God's sake
I think capitalism is great if you want
to do it just don't make everyone play
your stupid game I like for tonight I
don't make a grandma playing tick
warehouse if she loses
[Applause]